I want to talk to you about the
relationship between just stop oil and
you and the labor party if I may and
then we can clear it up once overall can
you accept that it to some it would seem
appear counterproductive to donate to
the labor party who disagree with just
stop oil
um that and then also to the protesters
themselves
well I don't see how overall it's kind
of productive I mean donations to the
labor party are to help them win their
next election which I think is the most
important thing that can happen in our
country right now uh donations to just
our boiler to help them protest and
until we have an election I think that's
the most important thing we can do to
stop new exploration for oil and gas and
then we'll see that we simply cannot
afford to burn
but you've heard what secure Starman
said previously he says just stop oil
should just go home and yet you still
feel that um secure St armor is in
alignment with your views
no I didn't say that did I I said my
donations to the labor party uh you know
there's logic behind them from my point
of view they need to win the next
election and and as far as I'm concerned
donating to Justin also is a logical
thing to do right now until we have an
election we have a government that's
taking us on a reckless path we know
that we have to stop burning fossil
fuels let alone exploring for new forms
of them this government are opening coal
mines oil and gas Fields spending 26
billion on a road building program and
expanding runways all of the things that
are taking us in the wrong direction
have you ever discussed just top oil
with secure
I haven't
is there any particular reason why not
I barely speak to him I think I was
speaking to him twice in my life and
only for a few minutes and so that'll be
the reason
some reports have linked your donations
to labor and labor turning its uh
changing its tune rather on blocking new
oil and gas exploration in the North Sea
do you think there's any connection
I don't think it's an actual true
statement labor haven't changed their
position as I understand it this was
first mentioned at Davos last year so I
didn't think it's a new direction from
labor and and look it's not some kind of
crazy left-wing idea either from me or
people like me or just got oil for
example it's a mainstream scientific
opinion it comes from the International
Energy agency from the UN we can't
afford to burn more fossil fuels if
we're going to avoid the worst of the
climate crisis that scientific fact
the unions two of the biggest unions as
you know disagree with you particularly
GMB and unite GMB Gary Smith saying it's
a naive and displayed a lack of
intellectual rigor and thinking to
suggest uh that the new oil and gas
exploration should be stopped what would
you say in response to that suggestion
by Gary Smith
I would say that anybody that thinks
that uh new oil and gas women will see
benefits us economically doesn't
understand how the energy Market works
during the energy crisis we paid 10
times as much for our North Sea gas as
we did pre the crisis it didn't save us
a single penny even though half of our
gas comes from the North Sea so it
doesn't matter how much more fossil
fuels we produce here it won't reduce
our energy bills as the government
claims and on top of that this
government is intending to give one of
those biggest oil fields to a Norwegian
State and Company and give them a three
billion tax cut to open it up that
company will invest just 300 million in
that massive oil field and it's years
since the taxpayer of Britain had any
money from the North Sea at all from oil
and gas it's naive actually to think
that fossil fuels can make us any money
or reduce our energy bills but they do
create jobs for his members I suppose is
that is what he's getting out there
yeah I'm sure that's right but the
alternative creates more jobs uh
renewable energy creates more jobs per
pound investor than oil and gas that's
also a fact
let me just just to just
Ice is very much in the headlines at the
moment
um do you support them when they I don't
know stop ambulances getting to
hospitals
uh I don't know if they have I I
understand and I hear there's a lot of
chat in in right wing media about these
theoretical problems and and you know if
they have I don't support it but look
there is a greater harm going on in the
world today last year across Europe 40
000 people lost their lives due to
excess heat driven by the climate crisis
that's not a unique event it's happening
all around the world it's going to keep
happening people are losing their lives
their homes their livelihoods and that's
a greater harm and we have to do
something about it and the people have
just stopped oil they feel great
frustration that our government are
taking us in the opposite direction so I
understand that
would you ever feel that you wanted to
go out and protest with them
maybe I mean you know often I'm a little
bit too busy I've been a protester in my
life against cruise missiles being
stationed in Britain for example
American cruise missiles many years ago
now in the in the 80s
um often I'm too busy but uh I certainly
you know completely support what they're
doing I think they're very brave people
because they are facing an authoritarian
Crackdown by this government in in legal
terms you know they're putting their
Liberty on the line to bring this issue
to public attention
um and you know it's a little bit right
now protesting in Britain is a bit like
protesting in Russia
I'm not sure not sure that's necessarily
true
um why did you why do you find my
question amusing
uh I don't know I think the whole focus
on just our boil is a little bit amusing
to be honest I think it's a little bit
overdone I think that there's a
desperation uh in the right-wing media
to find something to attack labor with
because flying in the polls uh kirstan
was doing an incredible job and uh this
is clutching at straws
yeah what would you constitute as
right-wing media
uh well I wasn't quite including you in
that but uh you know you might be on the
edges of it but certainly we saw some
hysteria in the sun last week claiming
there'd been a secret meeting between me
and uh Kia that had been revealed and
that was actually revealed by me in
front of six million people on uh the
today program when I said I'd had a
phone call within the previous week you
know that kind of Hysteria exaggeration
uh and and fear-mongering really